this is what the Prince of Wales wants
to highlight the annual Anzac day
commemorations but the focus couldn't be
further away as his private settlement
with the tabloids was publicly revealed
by his brother Prince Harry's court
papers say his Royal Highness William
Prince of Wales similarly brought a
claim against ngn which it settled for a
very large sum of money in 2020.
we don't know how much money William was
given or what his claim relates to but
this is an extraordinary Revelation so
too is Harry's allegation there was a
secret agreement between the royal
family and News Group newspapers a deal
Harry claims to avoid a repeat of the
leaked intimate phone call between
Charles and Camilla dubbed the tampon
Gate scandal Prince Harry stayed in
California and wasn't in court but his
presence was felt
Harry's court papers make huge
allegations against the royal family and
their wider strategy with the media he
says when he first made phone hacking
claims he was summoned to Buckingham
Palace by his father and the late
Queen's private secretary they both told
him to drop the cases saying they would
have an effect on all the family
newsgroup newspapers deny the
allegations and want the case struck off
they say Prince Harry's run out of time
to bring the claims that's for the judge
to determine during the three-day
hearing Laura bundock Sky News